Jason: This evening I am honored to introduce
our commencement speaker. Larry P. Arnn became
the 12th president of Hillsdale College in
2000. He received his BA from Arkansas State
University and his MA and PhD in government
at the Claremont Graduate School. He studied
as well at the London School of Economics
and at Worcester College, Oxford University
where he served as director of research for
the late Sir Martin Gilbert, the official
biographer of Winston Churchill.
From 1985 to 2000 Dr. Arnn was president of
the Claremont Institute for the study of statesmanship
and political philosophy. In 1996 he was founding
chairman of the California Civil Rights Initiative,
a voter approved ballot proposal that barred
race based quotas in state admissions, employment
and contracting. He is a member of the board
of trustees at the Heritage Foundation and
of the boards of directors of the Henry Salvatore
Center of Claremont McKenna College, the Center
for Individual Rights and the Claremont Institute.
He is the author of Liberty and Learning,
the Evolution of American Education. The Founders'
Key, the Divine and Natural Connection Between
the Declaration and the Constitution and What
We Risk by Losing It, and  Churchill's Trial, Winston
Churchill and the Salvation of Free Government
this last work is forthcoming.
Under his leadership the Barney Charter School
initiative was formed and is thriving, Founders
Classical Academy was the first school to
open as part of this initiative. Please join
me in welcoming the president of Hillsdale
College, Dr. Larry Arnn.
Dr. Arnn: Thank you Jason and congratulations.
Some years ago our younger daughter Alice
gave a commencement address at a graduation
in Hillsdale, Michigan where I was the commencement
speaker, and  I began by saying this is not the
first time I've given something other than
the best speech at commencement but this is
the first time I've given the second best
speech by a member of my family. Tonight I
am going to be third best. Well done girls.
Congratulations Jason and Charlie Cook and
Scott.
It's an awesome thing, this, I am transported
by it, it's one of the strongest things I've
ever seen. I'd like to recognize the parents
of the students in this school, seniors and
others. Would you stand up if you are a parent
of a student in the school. Congratulations
to you. I asked the students, I spent some
time with them this afternoon, they are awesome
also naughty. I asked them what the worst
thing was about school and I never did get
an answer from any of you. They were moving
their lips a couple of them but they couldn't
make up their mind whether to say what was
on their mind.
I asked them what the best thing about the
school was and they said in a heartbeat several
at the same time, they said, "Those people,
the faculty." You should be grateful to them,
it is a very hard job they do and they have
prepared themselves for it for years or they
wouldn't be any good at it. Thank you for
that.
I am going to say three things. How this came
to be, I had something to do with the making
of this mess. I am going to say why classical
education, what that is. Then I'm going to
say a word to these wonderful and ambitious
seniors. It won't take long. How it came to
be. I run a college, it's a very good college.
It is the best I think. It is a very stubborn
college, it's well known, we don't take any
money from the government and we teach in
a certain way. It's like this way, the way
they've been learning. Not many colleges do
that anymore and they used to all do it. People
who get around it they get inspired by it.
Our college has been very consequential, at
the Battle of Gettysburg there were about
50 young Hillsdale men in the worst place
on the battlefield and it might not have gone
the way it went except for them being there.
Why were they there? Frederick Douglass, we're
doing a statue of him on our campus now. He
was on the campus twice. Why did he come?
The same reason people come today, the same
reason you are here tonight. Something beautiful
happens when you learn the best things, especially
when the young learn them it's the best thing, and so
because we run that college that way important
people sometimes punch me in the chest and
tell me that we've got to do something about
K-12 education and I've always responded for
years, "What would we ever do about that?"
The most of the insistent of them sits right
there. He does, he'll say, "You've got to
..." You know, like that, he's a big man,
you saw him ...
By the way this is so important that I brought
my trophy wife to this thing. She's right
there and she should stand up just so you
see. If I understood it I would explain to
you why she married me but a long time ago
she did. Steve, big Steve, he would say, "These
kids, you know, they don't learn anything.
They're deprived of their chance. Why is that?"
I would say, "Well the reasons are very deep."
The things that have been mentioned here tonight,
the most beautiful things that have been said
here tonight are systematically absent from
the typical schools in America today. I'll
explain that. He said, "Well you have to fix
that." About the tenth time he said that to
me I said, "I've thought of something. Maybe
we could help some people start some charter
schools and set them up right." He said, "I'll
give you some money if you do that."
So now where are we? We're looking for partners
because we don't take any money from the government,
this college is never going to get a nickel
from the Founders Classical Academy, ever.
Whatever we do, we pay for. Our partnership
depends upon the school doing some things
that cost the school money, and the school
pays for that. So you see, we're making each
other miserable, and we're both paying our own
part. It's by the way exactly the way education
used to work for about 150 years in America.
The people actually managing the schools bore
the burden of it. Other people who helped
they bore their burden. It's a model just
like the old one. The responsive ed people
they called and we thought, "Gosh we don't
want to do this with some big old company."
Then we met these people, right? Then we met
Jason, and then we see all this.
Now Steve Barney's gift is he is a blubber
baby when he gets all upset about something
or something moves him he cries like a baby.
He's very good at that. He's cried over me
so many times now that I just do just whatever
he tells me to do. He tells me what to do
all the time. Thank you, Steve Barney.
I mentioned Phil Kilgore, the bald guy down
there who stood up before because he's the
one who actually cleans up all the messes
that we make and thank you Steve ... I mean
Phil.
Okay. Why classical education? Do you know
what that is? Did you know when you sent your
kid here? It's a weird thing. The first thing
to notice about it is there's a million very
powerful reasons not to do it and those reasons
are best known to the people who actually
do it. First of all it's hard, I mean do your
kids get tired, you parents? Do they live
under stress all the time? You know what happens
at Hillsdale College? In September and October
and then in January and February the beginning
of the terms it's as happy as Disneyland.
Then it gets to be late November and it gets
to be late April and it looks like a zombie
movie. Everybody's got these big bags under
their eyes.
I told these kids, because they're so serious
and they were answering my questions so amazingly
well like college students in a good college
I said, "Did you guys write a senior thesis?"
Everybody including Mr. Rhea who is by the
way a Hillsdale College graduate appear acting
like a grownup now. As is Gina, as is PJ,
as is somebody else I saw over there but I've
forgotten who it was now. I can't believe
they are all mature and I feel old right.
They all burst into laughter, in other words
that thing was the devil of a thing to do
right? I started asking them what they wrote
and it's amazing right? That's classical education,
one aspect of it. Why would anybody do that?
You have to learn Latin. Latin is a dead language,
that's stupid.
Here's another thing Skype, Microsoft owns
Skype and Skype sometime in the next six months
is going to set it up, maybe they already
have I don't think yet though, but it's working.
You can call anybody in the world and you
can have a conversation with them on Skype
and whatever language they speak, and whatever
language you speak it will translate for you.
Why would you learn any difficult language
except the one you grow up with? By the way
I think it might be possible to call somebody
on the other side of the world and have a
conversation with them in Latin, neither one
of you knowing any Latin. Would that work?
I don't know. That's hard to do. That takes
years. Victor Hansen, a great classics scholar
who teaches at our college and who is a good
friend of mine told me that it takes 2000
hours. That's a working year, a full time
job, to learn Latin or Greek. Then nobody
talks them today. Why did they do that?
It's hard on the parents because your kids
are working all the time. Think of the parties
that you've missed and the movies you didn't
get to go to. You're young right now, why
would you miss that, right? It's stupid, what
are you thinking? The faculty see, because
you know what they do in school today? A distortion
of fundamental fact about education. A distortion
of that fundamental fact has become the rule
in education today and the fundamental fact
is these people do the teaching but the decisive
thing is done by them they do the learning.
Because, you can't learn any hard thing, it
doesn't matter how wise or learned the person
before you is to help you unless you are struggling
with the thing hard. I ask them a question
that's very serious with me and I'm an experienced
fella at this kind of thing. I said, "Do you
talk a lot in class?" They all said, "All
the time." Right. The classes are a big argument,
they've got to be, everybody's got to be involved.
Then I said, "Are they boring?" Then about
six of them said, "Never." Then there was like a thirty second ...
three second thing and then a few of them,
"Well sometimes" they said. You see? But it's
hard because here's what they do in school
today. They believe that students can only
learn what they want to learn at any given
moment and so they should really guide the
activity of the day all day long. That by
the way is a great way to teach because it
is really easy. You can just let them do what
they want to. You see why that's a distortion?
Because these people are decisive but so are
these people.
I took our ... This is the best classical
charter school I know and there is only one
caveat that I have to enter on that and that
is the one in Austin, Texas that we in responsive
ed have started is run by the most beautiful
and important academic young woman in America
today, Kathleen Arnn-O'Toole. Her school is
only a year old and then they couldn't do
right now what happened here today, that's
just awesome. You see? They are needed.
When I took my Katie, now a PhD to look at
a college where I got a lot of my education
in California I said to the admissions counselor,
"What are you going to teach my daughter?"
She said, "Whatever she wants to learn." Nobody's
prouder of a child than I am of my daughters
and sons. I said, "You know she would be coming
here to get an education." The lady said,
"Yes." And I said, "The implication is she
doesn't have one." The lady said, "Well, yeah."
And I said, "Well why would she pick then,
wouldn't you pick? How would she pick, could
you give her some advice right now?" The woman
was of course flabbergasted. I said, "What
is an education by the way?" She said, "Well
you'll have to talk to someone else about
that see."
That's what's wrong with the schools. It's
an interior, introspective, relative to each
person, not seeking something outside each
person beautiful and fine. That brings me
to my second point which is why classical
education? What is it? When we speak of education
we speak of a period in Greece and Rome, not
all of the history of those two places, only
part of the history of Greece and only part
of the history of Rome. When we conceive great
things were done, why those two cities? What's
the deal about that? What did they do? Why
do we call them classical? You know classical
music and the classical period in classical
music dates from an era a millennium later
than that. So what makes it classic? Here we
have to think about the word classic. These
two speakers in different ways have prepared
us to understand what I'm going to say.
Classical is an adjective, by the way the
only thing I know about these kids over faculty
that they don't know as well as they should
is English grammar. They misuse their adverbs
and their pronouns. I'm very confident that
you'll be fixing that promptly. But leaving
that out of the count they're a bunch of highly
educated geniuses. Classical is an adjective and
the noun is class. What is a class? What is
it to be a member of a class? Here we have
the senior class. How did they get in? The
answer is they worked their tails off for
years. They wrote their thesis, they mastered
their Latin, they know their physics. They
can do their calculus. They stayed up nights
doing it when other kids were having fun.
Now, in a minute, they're going to get a certificate
that says that they have the qualities of
this class and a synonym for qualities is
virtue. They have the virtue to be members
of the senior class.
Do you see what that means? That means that
a class is a kind of being, this is a human
being, this nice lady right here. This nice
man here, not so handsome as this nice lady.
This is a human being right? They are very
different and there's different colors in
here and different sizes in here and when
we look across the crowd we think how different
everybody is from everybody else right? It
is hard to imagine just off the top of your
head, what do they all have in common?
But you know, if somebody happened to lead
a pig in here, right now, like somebody really
big might walk in. There is a Hillsdale College
graduate who is six foot eight and plays in
the NFL one of the best players in the NFL,
Gerard Valdere is his name. If he walked in
everybody would think how large he is, right?
But then they'd forget it. Whereas if somebody
brought a pig or a horse in here they'd think,
"Wow, what's that doing in here? It's a different
kind of thing isn't it?" You could say if
you wanted to, "I want to be a member of the
class pirates, murderers, thieves, liars,
ignoramuses, charlatans, right? Burglars."
Are there classes like that?
I'll tell you something funny, there aren't
because there aren't actually things like
that. Here's what I mean by it. The argument
goes these kids seem to read a lot of C.S.
Lewis. The argument goes some people think
that there's these good things in the world
and there are these evil things in the world.
The good things and the evil things are in
a great contest. Each answerable to some
great equal power up above. That can't be
true. The reason is if they really were equal
how would you know which one you called good
and which one you called bad or evil? There
had to be some standard that was reigning
that would let you separate the good from
the evil.
In the Star War movies right there's the force
and there's the dark side of the force. The
emperor is always claiming that the dark side
of the force is as strong as the other side
of the force. But then you've to ask yourself
the question, "Why do they call it dark? How
do they know?" Come to find out the only real
things are good things. That means a pirate
is an unjust person and a murderer is an unjust
person. Injustice is not a quality it is the
abnegation of the quality. When they become
members of the class of 2015 they become a
real thing, something serious, do you know
where that argument was invented?
That was invented in Greece by a man named
Socrates. Do you know what he did? He insisted
on this. He would always ask people what they
were doing and why they were doing it. They
killed him for it eventually because it's
extremely annoying. He was a nuisance and you know
he would just say the same thing over and
over again, "Why, why, why, why?" It is very
annoying and it's hard to answer and it always
drives you back. I'm an expert in torturing
the young, that's what I do for a living.
I make an excellent living torturing the young.
They come back for more, I don't get it.
But one of the things you can do is you can say,
"What are you going to major in?" They'll
tell you and then say, "What is that?" And They
never know, right? Like can you define the
word politics right now? It's hard to do.
You have to train yourself for years to do
it and they're young, they can't do it right?
It is easy to say that they like to do something,
get them to say that, and then ask them three
or four questions why do they like it. They
will eventually say that it is good, then
the minute they say that say, "What is it
for a thing to be good?" Several of these
kids know because both of those speeches contained
a definition of the good in them which is
a remarkable thing for this age you see.
But mostly people don't know because it is
hard to say what it is and Socrates did that
to people. He would never take the answer,
"It's the way we do it here." "It's our kind
of doing it. It's what I prefer." He never,
he wouldn't hear that. He would say, "What
is the right way for a human being not an
Athenian, not a Spartan, not a Persian, what
is the right way for a human being to live?"
Socratic philosophy is born in that question
and that is the question that the young need
to learn to answer. Classical thought is looking
for that most fundamental question in philosophy,
"What is it for a thing to be good?"
You know what they teach today? There's
a national commission on the future of higher
education, a Republican administration, and I
wrote the Secretary of Education, I won't
say her name. She's from this state, I hadn't
thought of that. I wrote her and I said to
her, "You know, didn't you leave out anything?
Because what you said was, "We have to have
national standards for every level of education
including this level."" She was proposing
for colleges. "Because if we don't have national
uniform standards we're never going to be
able to compete with China." She was interested
in power, you see? That means how did she
picture them? Factors of production.
Now it's terribly important to be able to
make a living and you're going to be miserable
if your kids leaving and you have to support
them for the rest of your life right? But
do you think these kids are not going to be
able to get a job with what they have learned
to do? Do you see? While they are learning
to do it, you know I know, Nathan ... Sorry Mr. Rhea,
very well back there. I know how he'll be
talking to them. He'll forever be telling
them how many things there are higher than
money, right? And there are many things that
are higher than money and yet you need the
money. They are being equipped you see by,
among other things, not placing money first.
They find their dignity as human beings in
that fact. Do you understand that we are raising
a generation of slaves?
Now my point to you, I want to tell you how
my own education began, I mean the serious
part of it. I always made As when I was a
kid. I told some of the football players over
there that I was kind of like them when I
was in high school, I was well-coordinated,
and I could play every sport. But I wasn't
big and I wasn't fast and if I had been I'd
be ignorant as sin today. Because I just would
have played ball the rest of my life if I
could have done it. But no I was good at something
else, I could make As and I go to college
and I'm studying, I got a great blessing I
met a teacher, a real teacher. I won an award
in the college for the best student in the
department and there was this mandatory class
in political thought.
I actually tried to use my prestige as a good
student to get them to waive the requirement
that I take this class. You can see what a
jackass I must have been back then. I was
very cocky too, we are reading Plato's Republic,
we are in book one and there's an old man
named Cephalus he meets first and has an argument
with him and he goes away. Then Socrates meets
this man named Thrasymachus. There are several
other Platonic Dialogues, Socratic Platonic
Dialogues that have as their title the name
of a sophist. What sophists were were people
who would take young people and teach them
to be powerful in exchange for money. "I will
make you prominent, I will make you eloquent,
I will make you persuasive and then you can
have whatever you want." Socrates gets to
talking with Thrasymachus, and the other people
in the room include Plato's younger brother
a young man named Glaucon, so do you see what
it is? The sophist and Socrates are going
to have a fight for the soul of Plato's brother.
Did you hear how many times they used the
word soul? I think they may know what it is.
So Thrasymachus announces, "Justice is the interest
of the stronger. Whatever the strong person
is says that's what the just thing is." And Socrates
destroys him. The way he does it he says,
"Okay, I give you that. So let's say you're
the strongest. I give you that, you assume
that you're that you're the strongest. Now
tell me what is your interest? What is good
for you? Explain that to me now." He says,
"Well what's good for me is whatever I want."
He says, "Is it? What do you want? Tell me
because you must wants things that are good
for you. What do you want?" He ties him up,
the Greek word is therion, wild beast.
Thrasymachus, it's very dramatic, you've all
got to go and read Plato's Republic tonight.
He says, "He rose up like a wild beast in
anger." You see, Socrates wins the young men.
Now then, and this is the part for you, then
Glaucon the minute that's over and Thrasymachus
is destroyed Glaucon, the younger brother
whose soul is at stake you see. He gives Socrates
a charge, he says, "Okay Socrates big talk
he says, you have to prove to us then, prove
to us he says that justice is good even if
you practice it you will be punished, and injustice
is bad, even if when you practice it you will
be rewarded. Show me that justice is good
for its own sake."
Now, that's one of the greatest books ever
written, one of the very few greatest books
ever written and the rest of the action of
that book is an answer to that question. My
point to you is you have to seek the answer
to that question. You are going to be successful,
just look at you, live well, do great, don't
surrender. Bless you.